c'est génial parce que du coup quand on
entend une blague il y en a d'autres qui
viennent dans ma tête génial et et
[ __ ] alors c'est un petit garçon qui
rentrent de l'école et à chaque fois
qu'il doit rentrer devant l'école ils
passent devant les prostituées et sa
mère lui a toujours dit tu fais un
détour
tu passe pas devant la victime que faire
un grand détour il a chaque fois y en a
une qui fait là il ya le petit garçon et
dîna mama on a dit que je pouvais pas
mérité pas les yankee fais ce que tu as
non baladi à la déco vous avez des
d'autres les jambes
en fait j'ai pas de job et à boire le
petit garçon il est dubitatif il
traverse est pas elle dit mais non on
coûte je vais pas toucher
je vais me coucher je m'écarte et les
gens je te montre je n'ai pas de dans la
norme ça je n'ai pas de dents dans ma
culotte mais c'est ma mère qui les
attend l abbé sa culotte
elle se couche à elle dit regarde je
n'ai pas dedans et le petit dit ça quand
je vois l'état de vos gencives
[Applaudissements]
je choisis qui mont alban a goûté à ces
deux mecs bout des os x est une monnaie
c'est des mecs de mekin qui meurent au
même moment ils arrivent ils sont dans
la salle d'attenté sont mans elles sont
là oh la la il ya l'autre il dit
tellement de quoi toi du coup on arrive
au même moment
moi je suis mort de froid jha merde et
le cicc est mort de froid et diallo tais
toi t'es mort de quoi des brêmois écoute
j'allais travailler on ma mais sur le
chemin je suis dit c'est bizarre ma
femme elle est bizarre ce matin je suis
sûr qu'elle me trompe
donc je suis venu chez moi je rentrais à
l'improviste comme ça j'ai trouvé elle
était allongée sur le lit
je suis si c'est pas normal qu'elle soit
allongée en plus complètement dévêtue
donc j'ai cherché son amant j'ai cherché
dans le placard j'ai cherché sous le
sous le lit j'ai cherché dans la salle
de bains et un moment donné c'était
tellement énervé j'ai fait une crise
cardiaque
le che des [ __ ] temps les charger
dans le congélateur très vivante
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]